chris wallace host of fox news sunday
and obviously the moderator at the first
presidential debate uh earlier in the
week
chris just when you thought this
campaign season could not get any wilder
it's gotten pretty wild within the last
24 hours
give us your you know sort of bird's eye
view of the effect of the president's
positive coronavirus diagnosis on the
state of the race
well it has a couple of effects on a
practical level it has absolutely
flipped the script because for how many
months now
has joe biden been largely confined
self-confined to his basement in
delaware
and the president has been out holding
rallies on the campaign trail
and now unfortunately the president
is is off the trail in that hospital and
there's talk about maybe at some point
when he gets
better feels better he'll do some
virtual campaigning and joe biden
is out on the trail not holding big
rallies but uh out
speaking uh on the trail so it has
absolutely flipped the script on in a
in a strategic sense it seems to me it's
a it's a problem for the trump campaign
because
you know there have been a variety of
issues over the course of these
last six months uh covet was the big
issue
then race then law and order in the
cities then with the death of ruth bader
ginsburg the supreme court
this brings covid back to the top issue
in the president's handling of kovid
and according to all the polls when that
is the primary concern
and people are asked who do you trust
more to handle the coronavirus crisis
they choose uh biden over trump by about
eight to ten points
one of the president's allies a guy who
helped him prepare
for that debate which you moderated
former new jersey governor chris
christie now
we learned earlier that governor
christie had also
tested positive for coronavirus now in a
tweet that he just put out we learned
that he's been hospitalized he writes in
consultation with my doctors i checked
myself
into morristown medical center this
afternoon while i'm feeling good
and only have mild symptoms due to my
history of asthma we decided this is an
important
precautionary measure so that makes
uh two of the well-known leaders of this
country
uh who have been hospitalized as a
result of this virus
you have to wonder how the president was
feeling the night of the debate
uh chris you know the the so many
questions are swirling
around the rose garden ceremony last uh
last saturday involving amy coney
barrett
uh a number of people who attended that
uh ceremony including three white house
reporters all have tested positive
for coronavirus now the president has it
kelly uh
uh his uh campaign kellyanne conway
leanne conway thank you for helping me
she tested positive as did well there's
chris christie who was there
uh so you have to wonder about that
event and how the president would have
been feeling 72 hours later
uh when you moderated that debate
well let me say however the president
was feeling he certainly didn't lack for
energy
during the debate uh some of us thought
maybe he could have
slowed down a little bit and uh had uh
more of a discussion and less of an
interruption but i i think you put your
finger on it
you know and we'll have to wait and see
what the science shows but that
event at uh the the
white house rose garden on saturday
afternoon almost exactly a week ago
right now when the president announced
his nomination of amy coney barrett to
replace ruth gator
bader ginsburg on the court we we've got
a graphic that we got ready for fox news
sunday
there are seven people either on this on
the stage the president or six people in
the first four rows of the audience
who have tested positive for the
coronavirus that there were over a
hundred people there they were packed in
the vast majority were not wearing masks
you've got two senators you've got
kellyanne conway
uh melania trump chris christie and
you've also got the president of notre
dame
the reverend john jenkins uh at uh
almost none of them with the exception
of tom tillis
uh none of them were wearing masks and
uh you can see how how crowded they were
there
and it really does seem to have been a
super spreader event uh
you know i know uh hope hicks has taken
a lot of heat but
uh just the timing the way it seems much
more likely
that this event is where people
contracted the coronavirus not what
happened
after the debate on wednesday all right
well uh
it is going to be a fascinating fox news
sunday uh tomorrow
chris wallace you'll have plenty to talk
about we thank you for coming on tonight